sometimes starring in a big hollywood
production can come with a cost i didn't
even know that was possible actors and
actresses pride themselves in their
commitment to their roles but sometimes
that commitment can lead to endangering
their bodies in fact there has been more
than a few times where stars were left
with permanent damages on their body
whether it be from stunts prosthetics or
a freak accident as soon as we wrapped i
went straight to the hospital
katniss everdeen has had to be brave
through countless treacherous situations
leaving her with countless bumps and
bruises over the course of the hunger
games saga that unfortunately rubbed off
on jennifer lawrence while filming the
second film catching fire the beachside
setting of the titular event in the film
required lawrence to do a lot of diving
which led to her going deaf in one ear
along with frequently getting various
ear infections for months after filming
a jet from one of the cornucopia scenes
punctured my eardrum
angelina has already proven to be a
top-notch action star by performing her
own stunts in films like maleficent and
lara croft tomb raider while filming
what jolie described as a ridiculously
easy stunt on set of the action thriller
salt jolie was required to roll onto the
floor jolie ended up misjudging the
amount of space she had and hit her head
hard against a desk while the injury
wasn't as severe as she feared it did
leave her with a permanent scar right
above her nose while performing a stunt
on top of a vehicle in a harness on set
of the third and final maze runner movie
o'brien fell off and was hit by another
vehicle the severe injury caused
production to shut down and o'brien to
be hospitalized with the right side of
his face being almost entirely broken i
have four plates that will be a part of
me forever i feel really lucky to have
come away from it in terms of coming
away from it at all on the day and
really how my face was healed because of
the severity of the incident o'brien was
cautious there was a time where i didn't
know if i would ever do it again and
that thought scared me too i don't
pretend to be something i'm not because
what you see is all you get in order to
portray the tele evangelist tammy faye
who was widely known for her heavy use
of makeup star jessica chastain who you
may know as the adult version of bev
marsh in it chapter 2 had to put on
plenty of prosthetics and makeup in
order to accurately portray faye the
makeup work was so excessively heavy
that it caused permanent damage to
chastain's skin but it's heavy and when
you're wearing it all day every day the
weight of it on your body it stretches
your skin out i finally took it off and
i was like i look 50 years old on set of
the marvel sequel thor the dark world
jamie alexander who plays the mighty
lady sif slipped from a high area
herniated a disk and dislocated her left
shoulder among other severe injuries
initially alexander thought that she was
going to be okay but after sitting down
in a car the next day she compressed her
spine and went paralyzed in her right
and left leg alexander ended up having
to go through physical therapy in order
to go back onto set she even had more
injuries on set of her tv show blind
spot but the damages to her body never
dissuaded her from continuing to
dominate the screen as an action star
for some reason keep breaking
the left side of my foot and i don't six
times in a row charlize theron became
pretty invested in her role as the evil
queen in snow white and the huntsman
theron was required to do a lot of
screaming on set
she is the evil queen after all but she
did get a bit carried away i did enjoy
just screaming at people i screamed so
much at people i tore a stomach muscle
which i had never heard of before rachel
brosnahan has earned rave reviews and
has won multiple awards for her starring
role in the hit series the marvelous mrs
maisel what's surprising is that the
show has had an effect on brosnahan's
body particularly from wearing a corset
on set all the time we talk so fast on
the show that to get all the words out
you can't really take very many breaths
and i think i wasn't breathing a lot and
i was a bit constrained and apparently
some of my ribs are sort of fused
together i can't take super deep breaths
anymore ryan reynolds loves to joke
about his role in the film green lantern
but he ended up with some battle wounds
from the set of the superhero film
reynolds was in dire pain most of the
film after he separated his shoulder
while filming though this didn't stop
reynolds from donning the red and black
suit as deadpool just five years later
oh god that hurt during the filming of
her action thriller the rhythm section
blake lively shattered her right hand
while performing a stunt initially
lively in the crew behind the film did
not think that the injury was too
serious but she ended up having to go
through surgery to fix the issue when
the initial surgery was not enough
lively had to go through even more
surgeries to fix her broken hand it took
months of recovery for lively before she
was able to use her broken hand again
which led her to take a break from
filming
and so there is no cutting out of it
there are no stunt devils there's
nothing so i'm really experiencing it as
the actor while tom hanks's role as a
gay man suffering from aids in
philadelphia won him his first oscar and
his role as a strandee in castaway was
beloved by many it did have a negative
effect on his health the constant shifts
in his weight as well as possibly being
genetically inclined led hanks to
believe that it may have been the cause
of his diagnosis of type 2 diabetes the
gaining and the losing of weight may
have had something to do with it because
you eat so much bad food and you don't
take any exercise when you're heavy
while filming the period action film the
eagle star channing tatum known for hit
films like step up and 21 jump street
had to trudge through freezing cold
waters during multiple scenes the only
way to keep warm was to have a mix of
boiling hot water and river water poured
down his suit on the last take one of
the crew members accidentally forgot to
mix the boiling hot water with much
colder water tatum attempted to take the
suit off to avoid being burned too badly
but the water ended up going to his
nether regions which led to some
permanent and unwanted damage some of
the stuff that they do on stage is
really intense and if you are having too
good of a time you might get hurt jackie
chan is widely known around the world
for his commitment to do all of his own
stunts in his films but this led to some
battle damage he's broken multiple bones
dislocated his shoulder on more than a
few occasions sustained concussions and
has suffered through several spine
injuries one particular stunt on the set
of his film armor of god 2 was perhaps
his most serious injuries which led to
permanent consequences it was actually
just a simple stunt jumping from a slope
but i was seriously injured and had a
surgery to my brain i still have a metal
plate in my head and can feel the
indentation from the impact oh my god
yes yes yes yes
yes despite the severity of the injury
chan was eager to continue doing his own
stunts in all of his films while filming
the first season of the cw series
batwoman star ruby rose suffered a neck
injury that left her with a pez
dispenser shaped scar rose was told that
she would need to have emergency surgery
or else she was at risk of becoming
paralyzed i had herniated two discs
doing stunts and they were close to
severing my spinal cord i was in chronic
pain and yet couldn't feel my arms i'm
pretty prone to injury myself whenever
daniel craig does press for a new james
bond film he always likes to say that he
did not know if he would want to return
to the role an injury on the set of his
second go-around as double 07 may be one
of those reasons while filming the 22nd
bond film craig received an unwelcome
face injury after a head-on collision
during a stunt because of the scar craig
ended up having to go through plastic
surgery in order to treat it
i've had my right shoulder reconstructed
i have had
this left knee operated on my right knee
operated on russell crowe is known to
pull off the rough and rugged aesthetic
in plenty of his roles but perhaps
gladiator is his most well known while
on set of the best picture-winning sword
and sandals film crow started to have
achilles tendon problems as the costume
designer did not put any heels in the
shoes he wore for the part he also ended
up hurting his shoulder and had to have
two operations to fix it if that was not
enough he now has a disintegrating hip
because of the physicality of the roll
from broken bones dislocations and worn
out muscles these stars never felt the
same after making their respective films
it is all the more impressive that many
of them are still willing to let loose
in their movies and shows thanks for
watching